someone just crafted a million dooll
Counter-Strike skin this is the one and
only case hardened AK that comes in the
so-called 661 scar pattern that is both
Factory new and Stat track for literally
10 years no one has ever unboxed or
crafted this skin until now now the
value is estimated to be anywhere
between 800,000 and a million us it's
literally the most expensive skin right
now apart from the caramate it's maybe
the most expensive sale ever happening
if guy wants to sell it you see there
are other Factory new 66 ones like this
one and there are stat track but never
both together now this is not
technically the most expensive skin in
Counterstrike but it is very close so
for those who don't know the thing that
makes the 661 so sought after is the
fact that the pattern has all of the
blue gem on the top piece of the gun now
I certainly wouldn't pay a million dos
for it as far as AKs go this is this is
pretty pretty up there